every time I think that I've had a crazy
year I lived the next year
this is human crazier kim kardashian
reflects on her whirlwind year now my
priorities have shifted so I'm really
excited for this year and what's to come
and the more that I can do to help other
people on Sunday's episode of Keeping Up
with the Kardashians who saw the family
deal with the aftermath of Kanye's
infamous TMZ live appearance I obviously
support him and will always but he likes
to speak for himself and I like to speak
for my thumb Dean while Kim worked with
her lawyers and President Trump to free
Alice Johnson from prison a woman who
served more than 20 years for a
first-time nonviolent drug offense the
president just called me and he tied me
[Applause]
[Music]
you can't wait to meet your family Kim
also made an appearance on busy tonight
with Busy Philipps where she further
addressed
Kanye's political views how do you deal
with it in your own how you deal with it
in your own house his thing is more like
I'm gonna fight for the freedom to like
whatever I like and her recent comments
about taking ecstasy did ecstasy once I
got married I did it again I made a sex
tape what happened a third time you know
here's the thing people that were close
to me that obviously know that that life
of mine yeah they're like I can't
believe you said that and I was like
well I mean I never really hide anything
know anything it's just weird to people
like I've done ecstasy but I don't drink
I don't smoke weed I don't I don't do
anything huh so it's weird to like have
done that but I think that I was so
young I would tell my mom everything we
always had such a close relationship so
I would come home and be like oh my god
mom I did ecstasy last night and she was
like she I remember this so clearly she
sat she was sitting on top of the
washing machine she like jumped up on it
we were sitting in the hallway
by the garage like in the laundry room
and she was like you one day you're not
gonna be able to have babies you can't
do this you're gonna ruin yourself like
she was so upset and she never did drugs
so she was just so upset thinking that I
was gonna like turn into something you
know and just be this crazy drug addict
and I just was like you know what she's
so right I'm so over it like this is so
not me and I just I never did anything
again
you
[Music]